In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 29th, on which we commemorate, the Holy
Martyr Galenicos, and the Holy Virgin Martyr Theodota and her three children, Christ's
Holy Martyr Galenicos was from Celicia, a generous man, having the faith firmly implanted
in his heart from childhood, he traveled through lands and villages to proclaim the good news,
and thus drew many souls to the way of salvation.
Arriving in Ankara in Galatia, he began to preach, exhorting the pagans to renounce
the worship of vain and lifeless idols, to come to the knowledge of God, the Creator of
all things.
The success provoked the hatred of some pagans who denounced him to Sassardos, the governor.
Summoned before him, Saint Galenicos confessed himself to be a servant of the living God
and declared that he was preaching the doctrine of Christ in order to save others from ignorance,
with the hope of gaining in this way eternal life, according to the promise in Holy Scripture
when he called on the governor to renounce idolatry himself, Sassardos in fury had him put to torture,
thrashed with ox sinews, Galenicos turned the eyes of his soul God words, thanking him for allowing
him to suffer thus, for love of him. Then, lacerated with iron nails, he mocked his torture
inability to make an end of a naked and unarmed man. Sassardos then ordered some men to
shoe him in iron sandals, studded with nails and cutting blades, and to drag him behind their
horses to Gangra in Paflogonia, about 80 miles away, to burn him to death.
Sustained by the grace of God, the Saint ran 60 miles in burning heat with eagerness,
almost outrunning his escort. When they arrived at a place called Matrica, the soldiers overcome by
thirst and unable to keep going, fell at his feet and begged him to intervene. Galenicos began to
pray, and immediately a spring of fresh water gushed out from a rock, as in ancient times for the
Hebrews in the Egyptian desert. It was later named the fountain of the martyr Galenicos.
On their arrival in Gangra, the grateful soldiers hesitated to carry out the tyrants orders,
and it was Galenicos himself, who, impatient to join the Lord, encouraged them to prepare the
pyre. Once the fire was a light and the flames were crackling, he was thrown into it, glorifying God.
The Saints' relics brought the Christians of Gangra, God's blessing, and help.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us and save us.